- [Mark] All right, Theresa.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Hey, Teresa, where are you from
where did you grow up?
- [Theresa] I grew up in
Los Angeles California.
- [Mark] South Central?
- [Theresa] South Central, yes.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- No, just my mom, just my mom.
She raised seven kids on her own
- [Mark] Where was dad?
- Doing his thing, you know,
papa was a rolling stone wherever
he laid his hat was his home.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- How would I beg your pardon.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- It was pretty good.
I mean, you know, mom
did what she had to do
to take care of her kids, you know,
and she believed in, if
she laid down and had you,
she's gonna take care of you, you know
so that's what, it was pretty good.
It was okay yeah.
- [Mark] No abuse, no
crazy traumatic events?
- Well, when I was six, I got molested,
so that led me to a wild
life of drugs and alcohol
and you know, being promiscuous
and stuff like that.
And at the age of 16,
I started prostituting,
I was using drugs and I needed
a way to support my habit.
So I started prostituting
and it led it into a wildlife,
of different things and
running to different people.
You know, once this guy tried to rape me,
and I just had to cut him up,
I cut his face up and stuff
and just have to do what
I had to do to survive.
He had locked the doors and it wasn't
he didn't have no thing
to open up the doors.
Yeah, and he tried to rape me
and I just had to do what
I had to do to survive.
He had closed, put the
child locks on the door
so I couldn't get out the car.
And yeah it was just all bad.
You know, he started
beating on me and stuff
and I just pulled out my knife
and I just started
cutting him up, you know
and he opened up the door pretty fast
after I started cutting him up.
But I had to kick out the window
for him to really open up the doors.
But that was one of my tragic experiences
that I've had since I've
been working in the streets.
And it's a wild world out here,
especially in Los Angeles,
California you know
you're right in contact
with all different people,
and they deceive you.
They pretend to be one way
and then they're another way, you know
and when you get into that car
you don't know if you're
gonna live or die.
And that's the chance
that you have to take
just to get, to maintain your habit.
- [Mark] Have you worked
with pimps before?
- I beg your pardon?
- Have you worked with pimps before?
- Well, it was one guy, it
just didn't make any sense
for me to give him my money (laughs).
He tried to and then he was a real abusive
and I seen what he did to the other girls,
so I got out real fast.
And then he was talking about
taking me to another state
and all this stuff.
And one of his friends a drug
he had seen him drug one of
the girls and I just got out.
I left and I never came back,
I was really scared for my life.
So that was one thing I said,
I'll never work for a pimp
you know, and I just do my thing.
You know, I get out
there, I make my money,
I pray before I get in the car,
and I pray to God that I make it out.
You know, it's a wild life.
- [Mark] What would you think
that keeps you in that life?
Is it, is there something
in your childhood
that maybe kinda makes that acceptable
and even makes you comfortable with it
or just because there's
other options for you?
- Yeah, well, when you using drugs,
the drugs is a fast way of
getting money, you know?
And when you use using, you have to
you don't have time to be trying to.
- [Mark] Do you think the
drugs drive the prostitution
or the other way around?
- It, well.
- [Mark] It works both ways isn't it?
- It works both ways, it works
both ways, it really does.
I don't like laying up having, you know
doing stuff for money and
stuff, but it's fast money.
You get in, you get out,
you gone about your business
you know and yeah, it's this is the man.
The prostitution life is really,
really is scary you know,
sometimes, they'll put the word out like,
oh it's this man out here
that's trying to rape girls.
Or this is grog man out
here trying to kidnap girls
or whatever you have to really like
have your eyes and ears
open and your visual all on,
so you can pretty much if the
description that they give you
you got to go off of that.
You don't have no other way
to know who that person is.
You know so it's just a
lot of prayer, basically.
- [Mark] Your intuition.
- Intuition yes all of that.
And then I don't date black guys.
- [Mark] I hear that a lot.
- I don't date black guys
because they're very abusive,
you know they're stealers,
they take, take, take,
you know, and nine times out of 10,
they wanna act like that you and I worth
you know, whatever you say
whatever I say my price is I want that.
I don't want you to try to down talk me
or try to give me what
you want me to have.
No, it doesn't work like that.
You know, you give me
what I want or I'm out.
So that's what we, I learned
to not date black men
because they're really shady.
- [Mark] And your drug is crack.
- I beg your pardon?
- [Mark] What is your drug?
- Crack
- [Mark] Crack.
- Yes.
- [Mark] How did that start for you?
- Like I said, it was
being, I got molested at six
you know I blacked it out, you know
and then when I was like 16,
that's when everything came back.
And I just didn't wanna feel,
I just didn't wanna think.
And somebody started me on to crack
and it was just a high,
a undescribable high
I've never experienced before you know?
And then from there it
just led to a life of crime
and you know, prostitution
and just all of that going to jail.
You know I'm not proud of it,
but it goes with the territory.
- [Mark] Is it difficult to be around
all these people that are up to no good,
you know, from the tricks
to the other girls,
to the cops, to the teams, to everybody.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Mark] It just seems like it
would be a hard environment.
- It is a hard environment
but you got to pick and
choose your battles you know?
So a lot of people I don't mess with
'cause I know who they
are or what they do,
or you know what they're known to do,
I just separate myself from that.
'Cause I still got all
my teeth over my mouth,
I don't wanna wear black eyes
and you know, be beaten
up or be getting robbed
or I don't wanna do any of that.
So I just, I really like stay to myself
and just do my own thing.
- [Mark] You were figure out?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- No.
- [Mark] Never married?
- [Mark] You've been in love.
- No.
- [Mark] Never?
- Never love my money, love myself.
- [Mark] I've heard that before.
Does your family know you do this?
- No, I, well, they probably suspect,
but they never like actually seen.
- [Mark] They might know now.
- Yeah, wow.
- [Mark] Does it gets you
depressed sometimes I'm sure?
- I beg your pardon?
- [Mark] It gets you depressed sometimes?
- Yeah 'cause this is, yeah,
'cause this it's not a life that you
this is not what I, as a child said,
oh I just wanted to go
up and be a prostitute,
that's not what was in the plan you know.
- [Mark] But what do
you dream about as teen?
- I wanted to be a nurse, you know
I wanted to be a nurse.
I love helping people.
I have a carrier.
That's why I have to
separate myself from people
because they'll hurt your feelings.
You know, you'd be doing stuff out
of the kindness of your heart
and you do stuff with good intentions,
and then they'll take that for granted.
So I've learned in his life
that you just gotta say
no and separate yourself
or you would get hurt mentally,
physically, and emotionally.
- [Mark] And the interactions
that you have with guys
who pick you up, you just do you actually
like any of these guys, are
you're just tolerating them?
- I just tolerate them for the moment,
you know, I tolerate them for a moments.
Yeah, I worked for the Royal
but since they had the cell phones
I work a lot off my cell phone now,
you know, where I don't
have to be in the streets
and do that.
And I have a lot of regular
Jones that I deal with it.
- [Mark] How many guys do you turn down
that will approach you on the street?
- Oh wow.
- [Mark] Where you just get
that you get a bad feeling.
- [Theresa] I get that intuition
yes, I work off the vibes,
you know, I work off of vibes.
I'll work off of my intuition.
- [Mark] So what kind of behaviors
or appearances do you
look for that straight on
other than being?
- [Theresa] A person that's too anxious,
you know what I mean?
Or just wanna ride by ride, by ride by
and just be, you know, I don't know
I don't wanna do that.
I'm not gonna date you if you do that.
And it's really dangerous
and it'll be 2020
'cause everybody's on something,
you know everybody's on
some kind of substance.
And you never know who's on what.
You need never know what that devil
tell them to do you know?
So I just try to follow my intuition,
my instincts and my first mind.
- [Mark] Are you saving money doing this?
- [Theresa] I have.
- [Mark] But just surviving.
- [Theresa] Yeah, just
surviving, it comes and it goes.
- [Mark] But what regrets
do you have in your life?
- [Theresa] I regret and picking
up that pipe, I regret that
'cause it has controlled my life,
you know, in more ways than one.
I've done things that I'm
not proud of you know?
So that's what I really regret.
Using drugs and I going to finish school
or not finishing out my dreams
and things that I wanted to.
- [Mark] What do you think
most people don't understand
about drug addiction?
'Cause as an outsider,
listening to your story,
they'd be like, well, no,
put the crack pipe down
and get a job and straight.
- Is that you have to respect it.
People don't understand
it, you got to respect it,
if you don't respect
it, it will smoke you,
and you'll be living on skid road
and you be because your mind,
once your mind go, your body gonna follow.
So you have to respect what you're doing.
You have to respect the game.
- [Mark] It sound like
you're not intelligent enough
to figure out that this is bad for you
you know damn well it's bad for you.
- Yeah, of course I do.
- [Mark] It's just very difficult.
- To get out.
- [Mark] For even somebody who is logical
and sensible like yourself to stop.
- Yeah, to stop yeah, it is.
It's a jones, some monkey on your back.
- [Mark] Have you been clean before?
- No.
- [Mark] Never.
How old are you now?
- What?
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- How old am I?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm 24.
- [Mark] You're 24?
I'm not sure about 24,
but I'll let you slide on that.
(laughing)
Does this kind of work
how does it affect your self-esteem?
Does it build it up or tear down,
or do both at the same time?
- Oh my self-esteem is out of the roof.
It really is my self-esteem
is like over the top
people they be like oh
you too you bougie, nope.
I'm glad you feel like that
but I need 100 more haters like
you by the end of the year.
Yeah, so over the top.
I pretty much don't let anybody
or anything get me down you know.
- [Mark] This kind of work
is not for every girl, right?
- No, of course not, you got to be strong,
you gotta have tough skin, you really do.
Only the strong survive out here.
You know, you don't have
tough skin and don't let you
you have to be, you have
to let your yes be your yes
and your no be a your no.
It can't be no in between
there are no gray areas.
Because if they see any kind
of weakness or gray areas,
they'll walk all over you.
- [Mark] What's the
craziest thing you've seen
in your years of doing this?
- Wow craziest thing I've seen
one girl get her neck slashed.
- [Mark] By her?
- By her pimp for not giving up the money.
She stashed the money in
a condom in her pussy.
He slashed her throat.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- The most important
lesson that I've learned
is to never give up on your self worth.
Never give up.
I know I'm worth more than
what I'm out here doing,
but at the same time is I have to stay.
I have to stay positive
you know what I mean?
I wanna live.
No, I try not to let no negativity
'cause when you let negativity
and it's gonna follow you,
you know you're not gonna
not even get what you came
to you sought out to do
because you have all these negative vibes
is going on with you.
So just trying to stay positive
and just try to stay true
to who I am, true to me.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give to a young girl
that's thinking of doing stuff like this?
- I would give her, if I stay in school,
stay in school learn
everything you can learn.
They can't take away what you know
they can put you anywhere
in the United States
but they cannot take away what you know.
So learn all you can and stay in school
and follow your dreams.
You know, don't let, don't
get caught up in a shuffle,
in a buffalo of everyday living
you know of using drugs and prostitution.
And it's just, it's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
Especially if you don't
have any tough skin
it really isn't, it's not worth it.
- [Mark] How is doing this kind of work
for all these years
affected your view on men?
- Oh, it's affected it, it
has, I don't know how to love.
I never been in love.
I don't know if I ever wanna be in love.
- [Mark] Do you respect men less
because of what you learned?
- No, I respect them equally
because at the end of the
day I can't whoop a man.
I can't beat a man up, you know
so I stay in my lane.
I stay in my lane and
maintain a lady at all times.
Because you put yourself
in a certain situation
or certain predicament a man
would beat you like a dog
beat you like another man you know?
So I just try to stay in my lane,
I maintain to be a lady at all times.
- [Mark] All right, Joan
well thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're so welcome.
- [Mark] I wish you the best
of luck out there be careful.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- [Theresa] Your welcome.